feel it feel the car creepin and a
burrito with some nice carbs okay Y
burrito just happened folks that was
what I feel like me my man
hey guys I'm Abby sure welcome to Abby's
kitchen if you tuned in last week I was
talking about the new hot Netflix
documentary at the magic pill and I was
talking a little bit about some of the
things that I thought that they got
right sometimes it was really dramatic
eyes but at least the concepts were
there so if you missed that video you
can check it out right here so today I'm
gonna talk a little bit about some
things that I think the documentary got
really wrong and I got a lot to talk
about so let's get into it claim number
one early humans only ate meat and fat
let's take a look we have the brains
that we do because of the enormous
amount of fact that we consume as a
species throughout our evolutionary
history suddenly now are eating a
carbohydrate based diet and in the last
30 or so generations since this thing
called the Industrial Revolution this
has just gone down a slippery slope so
much like things like the Paleo diet
the documentary makes the claim that the
keto diet was the way that our ancestors
used to eat in reality based on
archaeological and anthropological data
carbs were an integral part of the
growth of the human brain to the last
million years basically it carves made
the world go round
our ancestors probably ate a lot of
carbs mainly in the form of tubers seeds
and some nuts and fruits so to say that
carbs are new to the game is definitely
not true maybe refined carbohydrates but
not carbs period cool fact time so
studies have found that meat may have
kick-started the evolution of larger
brains
however starchy foods actually made us
smarter by providing our brain with
glucose to think I am really craving
some bread right now
[Music]
Tarbes claim to some really confusing
messages about processed foods let's
take a look at some of the most
cringe-worthy quotes years ago there was
a commercial for a particular Marjorie
that's not margarine that's my sweet
creamy butter this is woman who actually
turned out to be Mother Nature tasted it
and she said it's not nice to fool
mother nature made like thunder the fact
is that processed food is not natural
that's trying to fool mother nature
should I get the trash bag out we should
be eating the foods that nature provides
not better scientists not that factories
provide and this little nugget first
boils are toxic there are industrial
oils they are foods that we could not
have mean fractured until the industrial
era there are seeds that have oil in
them but that don't release their oil
readily so you have to use high heat and
solvents to do so that I hate the whole
toxic thing first of all let's talk
about this whole process thing that they
are demonizing and seeing it is so toxic
so the majority of our foods are
processed and that is okay because
there's a huge difference between
processed foods and ultra-processed
foods have you ever bought milk from the
grocery store yeah that's a processed
food it didn't just make its way out of
the cow's udder and then arrive
magically at your door in a lot of cases
processing can make our foods healthier
and safer
this documentary demonizes processed
foods as toxic however there's a lot of
really healthy processed foods that can
easily fit into a healthy balanced diet
meanwhile they are pushing tons of
coconut oil and cheese and bacon these
are all processed foods in fact I would
put bacon into the ultra processed
category yet they are all for all the
bacon in this diet so I would say that
this documentary really needs to either
refine its language
or refine its recommendations maybe a
bit of both claim number three all carbs
are bad so for a while now carps have
been demonized as the enemy and this
documentary definitely drives that point
home so let's take a look at some quotes
perfect get rid of it bread and other
grain related products are really
worrisome a because of their gluten
issue but most importantly because of
their carbohydrate content I don't even
know if we need anything about that yeah
I called wheat the perfect obesity food
perfectly crafted to make you fact we in
all frozen dinners all breakfast cereals
taco seasoning seasoning mixes instant
soup mixes canned soup salad dressings
in other words of a sixty thousand
products in the average supermarket
today fifty-nine thousand okay so what I
think the carbs I actually think of
fiber fiber helps us feel fuller longer
help us manage our weight reduce
cholesterol promote regularity and so on
and so forth conveniently fiber and
things like the difference between
refine and unrefined carbs are not
really talked about in this documentary
a systematic review of the literature
actually found that consuming lots of
whole grains like wheat which this
documentary seems to be really hatin on
with all the wheat wheat wheat wheat
talk can actually help to reduce the
risk of cardiovascular disease and even
cancer the bottom line is this
documentary spends a lot of time hating
on all the carbs and not talking about
the fact that not all carbs are created
equal and some carbs actually have
significant health benefits clean for
eat more animal foods instead of
plant-based foods so in this documentary
they kind of call for a complete
overhaul of the food pyramid where
they're suggesting you should eat more
fats and animal products and less fruits
vegetables and other carbohydrates like
whole grains so at one point in the
documentary they actually show the base
of the food pyramid with a burger with a
fried egg and bacon on top and I just
think it's really ironic that they're
trying to use a processed food like
bacon in order to make their point
sounds a little bit like mixed nuts
just to me brings carbohydrates really
has to be up in the tips and then below
that are fruits and vegetables and then
you know the big bottom slab really has
to be fats and animal food that is
actually what a healthy diet looks like
yes
that is what a healthy diet looks like
bacon egg burger hangover food amazing
so I may eat meat but I definitely see
the value in eating a lot more
plant-based foods from an environmental
perspective also the research has shown
a lot of benefits of eating plant-based
foods or like a Mediterranean diet which
is based around lots of whole grains
fruits and vegetables so my advice to
you if you're going through the keto
diet is to make sure that you've got a
good balance of animal-based proteins
and plant-based proteins and that of
course you're loading up on the low carb
veggies claim number five animal
proteins should be the sole source of
protein so this documentary and really
the keto diet in general makes a claim
that you should ditch all your
plant-based proteins like legumes and
and peas and chickpeas and beans and
instead get your protein fixed
exclusively from meat let's take a look
I've got a lot of mistakes porterhouse
steaks I've got came with the cow so I'm
gonna I'm gonna see what we can do with
it so like I said before plant-based
foods have cholesterol-lowering benefits
which obviously makes them super
heart-healthy this is not to say that
you want to avoid meat necessarily but
having some meatless Mondays and
switching things out between plant-based
proteins and animal proteins is
potentially a really good thing plus I
would say that the carbohydrate load in
sling like beans or chickpeas or legumes
or lentils is not that much of a big
deal I mean we're looking at about forty
five grams of carbs 12 impressive grams
of fiber 15 grams approach
in just about 270 calories no it is not
hardcore keto diet friendly but it's
really not a big deal and number six
food as the magic pill so I am all for a
food first philosophy but I think that
the magic pill takes us a little bit too
far so let's meet some of the
participants here who have come off of
their medication after going on the keto
diet
this is levothyroxine I take one a day
for my thyroid this is a tortoise that
it's for my high cholesterol this is
fennel fiber susana dying duloxetine
I kicked up for anxiety hydrocodone
michael tons of cream a pipette and
tablets
that's supposed to make your brain
process pain in a different way this is
pretty mild compared to this stuff this
is called on feet this stuff here is
it's over a thousand dollars a bottle my
insurance cover 70% so I get the joy of
only paying over $300 a month just for
this though okay so basically a lot of
people in this documentary have been
able to get off medication all together
after taking on a ketogenic diet which
is great and yes we know that food plays
such an important part in our health but
the documentary really makes a claim
that food is the problem and the
solution exclusively when we actually
know that it's so much more complicated
than that it always comes down to things
like genetic factors
lifestyle factors are you smoking are
you drinking are you exercising are you
doing all of those different kinds of
things it is so much more multifaceted
than just the food sometimes medications
or other interventions are the only
solution or are an essential part of the
solution so suggesting that you can just
go off medication and eat a certain way
is potentially dangerous even deadly
advice so the magic pill definitely did
get some things right when it comes to
the keto diet but there's a lot of
information and research that they
omitted to support their case I think we
need a lot more research to say with
confidence that the keto diet is the
magic pill for all of these supposed
illnesses so I definitely think that the
keto diet has some merits especially in
clinical settings however it's not
without its risks and it may not be good
for everyone
as always the best healthiest diet is
the one that you can stick to in the
long run and you have to find something
that works for you
not necessarily something that just
works for somebody in a film so guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below with your thoughts on
this documentary or the keto diet in
general subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]